Avengers assemble!
I've always wanted to say that.
My name is Peter Parker.
And life is pretty darn good.
Norman Osbourne is finally behind bars where he can't hurt anyone.
And after our last battle,...
...my deadliest enemies have all gone into hiding,...
...so hopefully they won't be making any trouble for me anytime soon.
Plus, I've got a new Spider-Girl protecting the friendly neighborhood with me...
...which allows me to spend time with my girlfriend, Carlie,...
...and focus on my new job at Horizon Labs.
I even have time to make new weapons and new costumes.
The world doesn't know what they're in for.
Looks like the Parker luck is finally changing.
Let's just hope it stays that way.
'Cause there's no denying, I've hit the big time!
And no one's gonna bring me down.
Let 'em try.